this is uh what I was always told is
that Marvel was people trying to be
heroes and DC was Heroes trying to be
people there you go so like
I noticed watching the Justice League
cartoons they always refer to each other
as their first given names Batman
doesn't call Superman somebody calls him
Clark Clark calls him Bruce they refer
to each other as people but they are
heroes and then the interesting thing is
Superman's identity is Superman Kal-El
and his secret identity is Clark Kent
whereas in Marvel often it's like Peter
Parker is the person in the secret and
secret identity is or like his you know
the costume is Spider-Man whereas for
Superman the costume is Clark Kent who
are you guys favorite superhero of all
time
Superman
I just as the definitive hero I believe
Batman Batman you like Batman better
that's why I was really disappointed by
the movie uh I love the the uh comic fan
Trope of given enough time Batman can
defeat anyone